so I have a notepad document of my of my
plan I was about to say evil plan but
it's just a plan so rather than going in
order or going in randomness I'm gonna
mix it up so the first challenge will be
a the first sub then it will be random
sub and then highest rated lowest rated
and then just my choice so I want to
just reward someone for being who they
are and then random viewer so even if
you're not a sub you could still
challenge and maybe get a game when I
get to this point so shall we begin
Risa Lion challenging me from position
wait didn't I play Risa lion in the rook
gods game oh it's rakaats part 2 okay
let's play the London feel like London
is a good opening when you don't have
this route I feel like also it's
probably preferable to be missing this
rook rather than this rook like in
Castle kingside
oh hello love HS welcome back but if I
place okay so the the usual plan here is
c4 which probably isn't so effective if
I don't have a rook on the Queen side
another plan here is Knight e5 and then
g4 fly your dog welcome back
oh dear it doesn't stop
I might put the fun YouTube uh we kind
of get the point I guess we get the
point
oh and it's not it's not detecting
desktop audio as so many things to fix
my desktop audio default okay so now it
should be detecting desktop audio okay
so I'm down the rook uh but I have nice
Center Bishop e5 is a the first move
that comes to mind like this move
threatening to to win material yeah so I
changed a source so next time something
happens it should it should be louder I
think oh dear oh but yeah it's not gonna
make any noise there at least for the
sheer ones you need to cheer at least a
hundred for text-to-speech Bishop d7 is
probably the best move oh my pleasure
thanks for the bits
akd um yeah so this is some small
victory
thanks for the mic check I mean the play
Bishop d3 so I basically took over this
diagonal I need blacks Bishop passive if
black wants to trade that and I'll get a
pawn and get initiative against the
Knights rookie mistakes gifting a sub to
mohanraj thanks so much
now I remember my opponents style from
the last game we played that the a lion
really likes to trade so I'm gonna try
and put myself in situations where
trades will benefit me I think this was
one trade that gives a lot of benefit
oh yeah 94 I don't want to trade too
much like if I take yeah doesn't mean to
anything
I would like to trap the night was a
move like f3 but the Knights Knights e5
not entirely clear if I should go for
that an interesting idea could be this
move before and then if we assume
something natural like this and then
like a three the whole idea is to play
off three in and kick around the night I
think I'll go for that also play
well let's place most played before
making the pawn useful yeah I'd be open
to doing collaborations later in the
future but I want to make up for for
yesterday so this will be dedicated to
two playing subscribers but if someone
else wants to like subscribe to my
channel and they're high rated though
they'll probably get a game oh let's
play a three yeah
so in general the structure is sometimes
taken advantage of with moves like c5 or
a5 but though the whole idea was
basically to restrict the night and some
sense of Bishop as well my next move
might not be f3 but might be h4 taking
away the the g5 square trying to slowly
suffocate the night
but see if I makes a lot of sense see
five I'm realizing there's increment to
this is probably the same time control
from last game ah
see five so if I play each four and and
takes enough three in the nights not
trapped because there's a night see five
so I'm probably better off playing off
three here and just chase some night to
somewhere awkward Tori Tori how's it
going thanks so much
welcome back hope you're doing well yeah
this is this is supposed to be a 90 K
sub celebration least a youtube sub
celebration but literally like 15
minutes ago I hit 91 thousand I try not
to look at the numbers too much but yeah
it's something to celebrate let's play C
3 just reinforcing the structure also
shout out to Tori GD always get the tea
and the d'emic stuff for some reason we
have a command for you so I've been OC
for interesting c4 I'm actually happy to
see gives me the square it closes down
the position I have been posting YouTube
videos every day for the last 25 days in
a row so that's definitely helped I'm
not sure if I can keep it up it's it's a
ton of work I do I do all the uploading
editing thumbnail stuff on my own but if
I can keep it up and yeah maybe maybe
100k by by the end of June also things
for the bits and Adam edible Adam Adam
it's able snowman thanks for the bits
with a sad snowman emote looks like oh a
melting snowball emote or something
so my knight wants to be here
but it's hard to get there I could mean
II knew her somewhere somehow pasado
thanks for the bits there's also sneaky
move Queen kind of like queen bee one
actually
it's like queen bee one it's so sneaky
I'm basically just trying to to focus on
the Queen side yeah and then take a free
night I'm not sure if my opponents
watching this stream that's this is how
magic tricks work it's an element of
misdirection you make your victim look
one way and then you you do things other
way thanks so much
mmm it's good to hear
really appreciate that's eye candy 46
that's a new name - yeah the ggressive
openings probably won't stop and Joe
brunoise comeback
Joe Brunner how's it going Joe Brune was
a victim of a raid last night but yeah
shout out to Joe Bruno kay let's
probably try and manage my time also I
think black hat g6g six would have in
some way trapped ambition I'll play h5
here this is only moved to defend the
pawn and prevent g6 and my my Queen and
Bishop evil a long-distance relationship
like there's social distancing but
they're they're very well connected and
these these moves an attempt to cut off
communication don't quite work if f5 I
take g6 I take and defend the bishop and
these two pawns do a nice job of
basically fixing these four pawns
the ship g5 is interesting maybe
expected like my opponent still just
wants to train and I can't really avoid
the train I'm thinking g3 because I want
to get more Center I think if I
retreated the bishop then I'd lose this
pawn and if I lose this pawn then g4
happens so you can downward spiral and
yeah if I take here then g4 is probably
very strong so I'm trying to keep the
position closed
I'm only down the exchange
we both have all of our pawns I have two
two sets of adjacent double pawns this
move looks nice over the last Queen h4
hey it's pure Quinn 7 1 3 gifting their
first son thanks so much
I'm trying to find a plan here always
have to be aware of blacks ideas of
chopping the bishop I don't think they
work just trying to find a useful move
it's like king king of two just in some
events like my team wants to defend the
pawn and now I'll play Bishop here and
go for a four yes and they kind of work
the same way as normal Suns also
speaking of thanks for subbing this is
Chuck 99 with a tier 1 son
oh well thank you appreciate that
oh this is hard to keep up with but
thanks again Chuck thinks big Alex for
the bits who is asking them the money
question um so revenue is split 50/50 at
least for Tier one in crime subs as far
as I know
so crime subs it's still 250 for the
streamer approx might depend on your
country
f5 interesting closing down the position
hmm
also harsh gifting subs thanks so much
I'm not sure I have time to think
there's a few ideas here I think there's
like three three ideas I could pursue I
could pursue a four could pursue and
just keen side playing coz g6 is weak
you also try and maneuver my Knights to
the center which would be very nice I'm
actually not sure what to start with
like I know blacks plan I don't actually
want to say blacks plan because black
might be listening as I play a four it's
kind of a pawn sacrifice might be a good
pawn sacrifice I'm gonna play a for
giving my opponent choices I'm trying to
create a situation where black could
very easily make a mistake
oh yeah my voice makes you sleepy I'm
sorry if you've all see if that's okay
happens to tell you all the time what's
good
most things are good but spamming all
caps in the chat is not good so here's
your lesson hopefully that's a lesson
yeah when there's no mods here I have to
to be a mod um which is okay I also have
to play chess rook Gaea ignoring my
ideas hmm I mean this is a whole point
that's to open the Queen aside in some
way black clearly knows like I didn't
want to say the plan of g6 but it's
probably pretty obvious black does want
to to open the kingside kind of a short
position coming up so I'm gonna play
Queen g1 it's hard to actually do
anything on the Queen side and now I'm
just preventing g6 if g5 I think I can
just take I'm prepared I'm prepared but
I have to focus on the game so let's
focus I don't understand this move
probably means I shouldn't start
maneuvering play not have fun
well Knight was doing nothing on d2 its
dreaming of the square this would be so
nice it has access to so many like on
infiltration points interesting I'm
gonna play this move hitting the pawn
and okay of course opponent wants to
trade oh can I take oh no it doesn't
work it almost works really almost works
I'm fantasizing about sacking like
sacking a piece not sure that's great at
all I'm fantasizing about this sign 93
takes takes oh there's no bishop he
hates I'm seeing ghosts okay let's play
Knight g3
so if Locke wants to trade Queens and I
get a pawn to g6 whoa it's Gotham chess
with a giant raid thanks so much Gotham
chess if you're just joining I'm kind of
low on time so I'm trying to not look at
the tracks or get distracted but thanks
so much I believe that was lovey people
should check out Levy's twitch and
youtube Ivy's been a ton more active on
YouTube and John being active with 15
subs adding to some distraction thanks
so much John but yeah this position
calls for focus because I'm still I'm
still down material also if you're just
joining I started the game down the rook
but now I'm only down the exchange the
knight has entered the promised land few
moves ago then I was on d2 so it's so
much happier like it's like moving from
a run-down apartment into like a nice
high-rise I'm building has a nicer view
newer appliances Oh what to do I think
Mikey wants to be on h5 it's a random
square but it defends upon for eternity
like the bishop is the only thing that
can attack the pawn and then if I just
put my king on h5 I don't have to worry
about the pawn and then I'm gonna try
and focus on the Queen side that's a
really funny position actually it is
hard for for either side to make much
progress and sometimes these positions
call for a lot of creativity
curious if maybe black will do this I
don't know in the vent I I take them the
file opens that's probably not a good
move though yeah so I'm gonna prevent
each five and yeah the like neither rook
can ever attack this pawn so I'm
controlling f6 preventing the spawn from
moving normally I would read off some
names but there there's so many and I
still still have to move quickly
what to do so okay I was gonna say
there's a few ways to like try and make
progress one way is to like dance around
with my knight yeah I'm just gonna dance
around and hopefully I stumble into
something good
another idea is efore but probably
benefits black more than me I am looking
at every score on the board trying to
figure out like where is my knight
happiest like c5 maybe but it's hard to
get there
Oh Locke wants to do this interesting
another idea is stacking that G sacking
looks fun but not called for and play
this move this could be a very long game
Oh people cheering but the the sub
alerts are still happening also 27 subs
what's the significance
oh maybe someone's someone's birthday I
don't know I really shouldn't be
spending so much time for a move I'm
trying to figure out if it makes sense
to treat bishops it might whoa okay
opponent opponent just got careless for
a moment yeah I was expecting busy g7
and yeah once a six is lost everything
crumbles I have five pawns across three
files let's play yeah I was just play
this move and g7 is gonna be week d5
will be week oh we broke ah maybe that
that crossed I crossed over because of
the total [ __ ] count is one thousand
three so 27 27 helps to break that the
four digits thanks so much again John
and thanks to my opponents gifting so
many pawns
yeah these pawns are to be reckoned with
I was gonna say like there is
or maybe there was some possibility of
like quintuple pawns if there is some
some of these captures but at this point
it's not happening oh it's still a race
I just got careless here here here here
yeah I got careless well this isn't so
simple I should probably push
you're probably queen and then and Queen
this pawn it's actually a little bit
crazy how quick this this pawn is mmm
debating with between f6 there's also
this move might be the best move
actually because when I play this with
tempo and then there's some not of fate
ideas that's like crazy finish though
turned into a race well you know fate
doesn't work a little or doesn't it
might f6 here here Queen Queen that's
winning
oh that's awesome tier that's very nice
to hear yeah I kind of messed up sort of
okay I'm just gonna I yeah this should
definitely work I have three pawns on
the seventh rank like usually if I have
three pawns on the seventh rank I'm
messing around I think this is the best
way to win that's weird I got relaxed
like for a moment there I thought like
anything would win win and then black
out the past pawn and then it wasn't
super simple but basically what's gonna
happen is blocks from the Queen I'm
gonna win the rook and blocks gonna
maybe try and check me a few times
I'll find safety I'll probably end up
making another queen - yeah I think to
the bit giver is it was X gold something
X X and there was dr. noha mu I have to
check you out on twitch okay yeah I'm
potentially making two more Queens my
king should find safety in the corner
this pawn will actually give me shelter
your queen
thanks for the bits sure Quinn sounds
like a new name I don't remember like
pronouncing that name before
okay yeah blocks run out of checks but
maybe not out of hope soon to the Isle
of hope hopefully yeah let's just trade
Queens
opponents praying for stalemates it's
hard to get stalemated though when you
have random pawns that can move there
goes one pawn I think all I'll do I'll
just meet with the Queen in the night
so if here it's me here I do this and
then it's made in like one or two okay
that wasn't an interesting game
different phases stacking like this long
close middle game I think this is a
general strategy either when you're down
this case like I started the game down
the road or when you're down the
exchange you do want to keep files
clothes to prevent your opponent's rooks
from from doing damage it's blocked in
plunder
yeah if blocked in plundered basic pawn
then I don't know how I would have made
progress
it's funny the engine per first block
here I was thinking why it has all like
only possibility to win cuz it's like
black really has no clear breakthrough
it's probably objectively just to draw
anyway thanks for the game Risa lion
maybe that was another youtuber V game
rook odds part two records I'll
brainstorm with the title anyway YouTube
people don't forget to Like and
subscribe
it's been working I feel like I've been
saying this more as it's been working so
keep it up and I'll see you in the
future